[Music]
in gangster richy-rich news euphemized
what's that submitted by rhythm by snore
snowboard bro a rich kid charged with
murder upset parents by attending school
while he was out on bail oh you're not
supposed to go back to school well this
kid is tart charged with murder he's
still going to school with other kids
how responsible I mean I don't know what
the laws are so you're supposed stay at
home well it's not that he's supposed
who's just like it's like as a parent
like all these other parents they
complain because they're like I don't
want this kid that has been charged with
killing another person going to school
with my kids what is he supposed to do
school it's cuz you not on bail right
now on a five million dollar bail yeah I
guess army like I was just thinking of
like okay figure out on bail
like can I go to the supermarket I know
I'm you know I'm charged for murder but
can I go swimming can't blow my nose at
McDonald's like I'm just trying to
figure out what am I supposed to do so I
didn't know you can't go to school if
you got charged for murder
I get like he legally he can is just
that the the parents of the school were
against that and so that that's what led
school officials to look into him and
then the parents ultimately his parents
ultimately said okay we'll pull him out
of school
eternal murder Shannon yeah is it wrong
that I thought what a good kid because
after you're accused of murder the first
thing you do is go to school because if
that was me somebody conceived I was
like I don't want to murder her around
me what depends on the murder for me
like if it was like a drunk driving type
of thing like I'm like okay you just
share a five million dollar bail who's
not a drunk driver murder yeah what did
he do and Plus whether or not someone
has murdered doesn't change my
perception of that person in my mind cuz
for me I think everyone's a murderer
they just haven't done it yet but if you
push people anyone enough they'll kill
someone so like test doc so if I'm in a
classroom and this guy killed someone I
would just be like oh you killed someone
okay cool
I think it's true because I watched The
Walking Dead and when people are pushed
to their limits they will kill but
that's a survival type of you know like
we're talking about with the murderer I
don't know if I would even classify a
psychopath or sociopath I think that's
different maybe I'm thinking of him as
like social game shooting boom boom boom
and blasted each other like I mean I
knew like tons of people like all Robbie
he's a rich kid so if it was like a
gangbanger right like he will he's
supposed been shooting people you know I
mean but in when he's at school he's a
regular civilian this is a rich kid so
I'm think he's a psychopath maybe that's
where I'm going
I was thinking The Godfather so he was
he's a rich kid but because he's tied to
the Mafia and then he's avenging his
father's death so which is it what did
he get what do you how do we do someone
but like to make assumptions about
things what about the murder okay duck
Miska his name is Cameron tyre Tyrell
he's 18 years old he dope-ass name he
goes to the Paulo's Verdes California
TV his parents so he's the son of a
South Bay interior designer and a media
consultant based in El Segundo that
that's what his parents do that's right
around our backyard yep
and so apparently he was connected to
this gang-related shooting and so
they're saying that about 11:25 a.m. on
October October first he he saw these
three men walking on the street him and
a friend Cameron and a friend and so
they approached these two guys or these
three guys and asked them where they
were from like hitting him up Cameron
hit them up Cameron I remember ins gang
bangin he's a Palos Verdes gangbangers
rich how do you get somebody up with
that Pepa money what are you trying to
rob them I remember there were rich kids
though trying to be gang bangers because
like maybe their parents weren't giving
them the support and love you know he
would he would be going to like South LA
all the time and so apparently he joined
a predominantly black South LA gang but
they don't know
okay so he's a white guy so oh wow
so white guy that had a rich white guy
that put himself eating the ghetto to
join like the gangs and he hit people up
that smell the Most Wanted is literally
malleable but the but the real kind
because you know what they say about the
token white guy in the black room he's
crazy
token white guy in the black group is
the it's the most dangerous one cuz he
always got a perm so he has to prove it
he has to show how crazy I bet you this
will last cornrows yeah so then wouldn't
you approach these three dudes
where are you four guys from so
Cameron's friend apparently just started
shooting at this and so he ended up
shooting 21 year old named Justin Holmes
that sucks and they weren't even gang
related at all like Holmes and his two
other friends they weren't but he ended
up dying in the on his way to are in the
hospital what if he was like oh what's
your name and he's like Camden Holmes
and he's like oh you're trying to get
crazy with me I'm not your home [ __ ] you
know I think I know what happened there
since they're [ __ ] they just wanted
to like pump each other up and make each
other feel tough cuz I've seen this
happen I've seen like some of them more
like [ __ ] gangs to pump each other up
and feel good they'll just straight-up
hit up people that obviously aren't even
in Europe to Punk them and they feel
hella good about them yup I've seen that
you know like what the [ __ ] you straight
[ __ ] you know they're not gonna do
anything then they would hit up normal
people thinking that they're gangsters I
think mine is more true this was just
going to like they go to a [ __ ]
senior citizen holy [ __ ] [ __ ] you beg
cousin dare you to raise that cane homie
I've seen that happen dude I saw I was
with my friends cousin who was a part of
that fake thug crew and we went to go
watch movies and they got Punk'd because
they were mad dogging some kids but
they're like older Korean brothers came
and [ __ ] Punk the [ __ ] out of it oh
[ __ ] we were laughing at him like
hardcore and we didn't even end up
watching the movie cuz he was so
embarrassed
so we leave right and there was this new
driver with his grandparents and he
almost backed his car into the guy
so once he hit his little bumper he got
out of the car he pulled out those
[ __ ] baton how cute I just pictured a
bumper and a good clown car yeah so the
the the new driver backed into my
friend's cousin and it boom so he's like
oh hell naw he came out he [ __ ] winged
this Pathan around and in the old old
grandparents were like scared and [ __ ]
and I'm all like that doesn't make you a
tough guy that just makes you [ __ ]
predator like you're just [ __ ] with
old people you're a bully
you don't look hard but I think they try
to like make themselves look cooler
because we just witnessed them getting
their asses pump and it was only one
Korean guy like one older brother that
came in and punked all of them and this
is supposed to be a gang yeah so I
probably this is probably exactly what
you're talking about they're pumping
each other up and oh yeah oh yeah dude
from whatever and they're like let's
just [ __ ] shoot at him you know she
was [ __ ] [ __ ] right those these
all's bookmarks like that you mean the
guys in the Batman outfit Cameron's
friend was shooting they both ran into a
black car which Cameron drove off and so
he was pretty much like the getaway
driver so you are stupid I wish I was
you as a kid like having money and [ __ ]
Danish it would have been nice [ __ ] gang
banging dude like Joe said he party
didn't have any loved gangsters I love
to which would you rather have a [ __ ]
ton of money and no love but our
situation cuz we had love as latchkey as
we was broken home as we was I feel like
we still get way more love than the kids
the rich kids that don't get nothing
it's so weird
man it just so it blows my mind what
what's weird just like watching like
kids like that cuz I didn't know throw
it all away I didn't know rich kids like
that but I know kids who were more
affluent who did that you know I mean
they weren't rich though but to us they
were raised yeah but not like a PV yeah
cuz it was one kid that shot himself in
the arm and he came to school and he was
like yeah man
[ __ ] and then his older brother totally
pull everybody that he shot himself at
the arm accidentally we know a very
affluent person in that area that has a
very sad family life yeah very very sad
family life
it's like money's not everything man I'm
greedy ass bug but I know the
consequence I know that's why I gotta
balance it I have self-respect I want a
lot of money but I want a lot of friends
that are real it's so angry it's not a
new gang sign oh he's wearing a LV very
expensive belt yeah his home is like 1.7
million like oh my god that's actually
cheap in palos verdes i know their
average I think it's about 3 million of
palos verdes oh yeah they even pointed
out in like the media reports that he's
like the lone white guy in a music video
with the whole bunch of black people
it's like this
I like the names Chico Cinco Casper
Joker and those are cholo name yeah
there has to be a Casper and a joker of
course
what's up Casper mr. Joker saw his buddy
shot the dude he didn't shoot him he
Danish you because you had the getaway
car I see or that's just what the lawyer
saying he killed this is justin home
maybe he was rapping too and they didn't
like it they had rapper beef oh my god
we need to change the world man I don't
know this kind of [ __ ] was still going
on yeah me neither
well I hope this kid rots in jail
forever because you had every
opportunity that other kids don't have
and you chose that life so since you
chose it instead of being an
environmental thing you deserve to get
[ __ ] in jail what's gonna happen is
his parents gonna pull connections and
then judge helps them get off easy or
some [ __ ] I'm obviously a sorry-ass
parents are you dude he [ __ ] murder
somebody and you'll pay five million
bail
so so he got arrested 11 days after the
murder right and then he got out on bail
the five million dollar bail and in a
couple of days after he got out on bail
Hugh was posting on Facebook photos of
him and his
parents at a doctor game for the World
Series wow wow you're a terrible parents
if I'd literally murder somebody
my mom would cut my ass off like I never
existed dude she's cut off her own
family because they don't give her phone
calls oh yeah and that's why we have
love and dado damn he took her to the
Dodger game that's what gets a lot of
love I think he gets everything yeah I
think he's just a piece of [ __ ] he's a
psychopath World Series - that's gotta
be expensive yeah yeah not guilty Andy
you know what I like to picture that she
doesn't spend any time with his family
and all that [ __ ] but the World Series
thing really just changed the game for
me he gets a lot of love but technically
he didn't pull the trigger though we
don't know that but that's what the
lawyers oh we don't know what happened
because he might he could have been the
one that went but then the lawyers like
no he was just a getaway driver
yeah that's true if I was rich too I
would use all my money in the whole
entire world to get my kid off of
everything really he'll [ __ ] yeah sure
you got so pissed that you you punched
another hole in the wall because of
another affluent kid that we were
talking about he got off the Illinois he
killed his dad oh yeah he did he was
ungrateful and he murdered his dad yeah
oh that's true if I had a Dexter for a
son that society's fault
[Music]